okay so we all know blue lions is the
best for the sake of argument
you picked black eagles i also picked
black eagles
okay that puts the black eagles on top
and that's not good
but you're halfway through i'm gonna run
i'm gonna represent the deer halfway
so you you know what they're all about i
know what they're all about we've all
played quite a few hours of this game so
i picked blue lines first
and i'm halfway through a black eagles
run so why did you pick
like like right when you started what
was the reason why did you
say like blue lines is what i'm gonna
pick the students
so at the beginning you can like do that
like here's a sentence about everybody
um i think all the students like get
pretty fleshed out throughout the course
of the game
but on first blush like meeting the blue
lion students i was like oh i like all
of them
they're nice they're not like felix at
first he's like kind of a
felix is kind of sylvain the skirt
chaser
see when it comes to anime boys that's
that's
what i do like so i was like okay i'm
gonna pick the tunde dude
and the the flirt and then and then
there's like
ash has a really good ability he's like
a pure little baby but he can
pick any lock yeah but you don't know
that when you first pick the house
because like they give you like
you could look at their you can look at
their info i just listened to the
thingies but okay i did a lot of reading
it took me a long time i like
i was really stressed out about it but i
picked blue lines and i didn't regret it
i really liked it without skipping a
beat i picked black eagles
because that'll guard yeah that's it
that's
why i picked black eagles yeah wow she's
a badass and then i'd pick that one yeah
i mean like
we know that the black eagles is
obviously the most popular
house judging by the online stats and
it's really easy to see why because they
are a badass house led by like a badass
woman who's going to step on you
um but yeah yes
that's the one thing blue lion doesn't
have going for it i think black eagles
and golden deer if we're talking about
house leaders
you got like the two hotties on either
end right and then dimitri's like
he seems kind of boring he's kind of
vanilla it's pretty uptight
yeah but i think he has a really good
arc
to stick with him and dead away his like
retainer like bodyguard character who
you can't recruit from another house
has like his story is all about racism
and like
he loves gardening and he's so pure and
there was this like twist with him
he's the one i'm supposed to give all
the gardening stuff to you yeah
now i know you picked golden dew though
second time yeah i think
golden d was by far the least attractive
house uh
when i was first starting the game but
on my second run through
uh and knowing the major beats of the
story i was most curious to see what the
golden d would do
after the time skip but i definitely
learned to love golden deer a bunch
because
the reason why the deer are so great is
is on one side you have edelgard and the
empire being like well
you know we're a very serious business
kind of thing and you have
demetri being like oh we're monarchs and
we're very into ourselves in nobility
uh but claude and his ragtag group of
misfits they just don't give a [ __ ]
about anything
like claude is just like a jokester and
all he wants to do is like play pranks
and like joke around with his students
his retainer which is like uh hilda
which is the the dejuay and uh hubert
uh equivalent she like has nothing
she just like wants to do nothing she's
respect she's not
into this this kind of this this three
houses [ __ ]
all their support conversations with
male characters you're just like hey you
fight for me and i'll stand behind you
you do the work for me yeah yeah which
is funny because
you know on the battlefield she's
in the front lines just hacking down
dude um
but yeah they they they addressed the
potty house um
i saw them described as pastel [ __ ]
patrol
pastel buy more so yes that was an
important part i
am enjoying the golden deer because
that's what i'm playing on my second
playthrough but they do have two of the
worst characters in my mind
they have three of the worst yeah
they're a house of extremes
so i know one of them is lawrence yeah
lauren
sucks he is irredeemable the only the
only good thing about him is that uh
after the time skip his hair gets a
little bit better
better than that he sucks his hair does
get a little bit more fashion
a little bit better a little bit yeah
that you know a lot of the hairstyles
get
really good after the time you know
except for ferdinands
oh i like ferdinand pertinent looks like
he looks like you know in stardew valley
the guy who lives on the beach
oh he's like i don't know his name
because i called him fabio the entire
time
he that's what ferdinand looks like i
hate his stupid haircut anyway continue
so lawrence lorraine sucks like i
you know i feel like every character i
started off hating had a redeeming arc
except for lawrence yeah like his whole
thing is like oh
i'm using my nobility for good you know
and like but then
at the end of the day he's still like
just really all about his status
yeah and yeah he sucks um ignatz
is a bit too much of a weenie
weenie her junior i mean there are a lot
of weenies like ashes of weenie
bernadette as a weenie
but ignace is the weeniest stuff is the
weeniest he's like i don't even want to
be
he's like super weenie i just want to
paint pictures
i don't want to be a knight i'm just you
know i'm the second child the best is
when like cythia just tears into him for
the support conversation
he's like if it was a different
character i might feel bad but because
it's him i'm like
let's go yeah but let's come on he's
gotta he's gonna stop painting you gotta
do something yeah i feel bad for him
okay who's the third one
uh i think well i was going to say
marianne
uh i don't know much about marianne yet
actually so she's
her whole deal is she's like uh
uh if bernadette got a gritty reboot
like
like if bernadette was like like 60s
batman
oh my god marianne is like the batman
batman
batman begins version because she's like
i don't want to talk to people i can i
only want to talk to animals i'm useless
i just want to be
away from people like she has like
suicidal tendencies almost
and that she eventually comes out of it
and you know that's all fine but you
know it gets a bit
much at the beginning yeah all the
support conversations are heard just not
talking
whereas bernadette at least like is
funny her support conversations are
really funny
because she's just like she faints
standing up or she like
yeah freaks out because someone carries
her yeah i've put a lot of thought into
this and i think the reason why
black eagles is best is because of
bernadetta oh yeah yeah bernadette is
great
petra's really cool oh i love patrick
exactly petra bernadetta
dorothea like both golden deer and
black eagles have some of my favorite
characters so i'd say like like cythi is
one of my favorite characters
i'd say bernadetta petra i really like
darthea
but i think both those houses have like
one or two characters that suck
so like ferdinand sucks
to be fair to be fair i wrote this in my
review
i do think and like i said earlier i do
think characters have good
like arcs and even the characters that
are just like an archetype so my defense
with sylvain
would be his arc is about like
why he doesn't value relationships
and i really like it actually yeah but
ferdinand's interesting because like he
has to come to terms with
like what his parents have done and
trying to figure out where he fits in
so i i think his stuff gets pretty good
i don't love him okay but you don't like
casper
okay yeah i love casper i don't like
caspar
maybe it's because i haven't just like
you know just because the english
i'm playing with the english voice and
he's pretty annoying i think
kaspar is one of the most anime
characters in the game
like he's a very gung-ho shonen
character okay
he's like yelling punching like when you
click on him in battle he goes you're
sure
there was a conversation with i think it
was like him in hubert maybe and hubert
was like telling him to be even noisier
because you were wanting to get killed
that's right he's like yeah you should
be even louder i kind of like
i mean hubert is a jerk but i also kind
of like him because
he's like super goth he's very gothic
anyway i should be talking about the
blue lions so the blue lions don't have
anyone who sucks
their whole story arc is about like ash
though yeah
what yeah his ability is really good
but again ash just wants to help
he grew up poor he wants people to have
good lives
he doesn't judge you for being poor what
was this was
yeah but i don't buy it i don't buy it
it's his ability
yeah but but his his character the way
his character is written yeah he's just
it doesn't seem like he was a a bland
face it's got a bland haircut
just a bland dude all around wow
i like ash and i think he has really
good support conversations with ingrid
where they both get excited about books
i'm not i'm i'm not books are boring who
reads
we're playing video games anyway felix
is a hottie
and i love him phoenix is one i've
recruited every time because
he is so good on the battlefield yeah
mortals
all the way he rips through everyone you
can just send him off by himself
like his ability is actually like it's
lone wolf i think and so he can't like
equipping a battalion
like makes his stats go lower so i just
like send them out and like i'm
gonna just use either magic or sword to
take out literally any enemy that comes
your way he's definitely a tough one to
like though i remember there's that
conversation
where it's like i need to find my
strength he's like i can help you he's
like no
if this is gonna work out you can't help
me it's like yikes
he protects himself because of the way
his
father treated him
and i yeah i think he's real i
came around on him i like him cool yeah
felix is a really versatile character
and so is ingrid
of the blue lines as well oh i love
ingrid she like
ingrid starts out a little bit she's a
little bit
bigoted towards the people of dusker
it's like dead away like she has like
this weird standoffish relationship with
him
but it's because her fiance was in the
tragedy of dusker
and then she like learns like oh i'm
being prejudiced for no reason
and and then she has like little things
with like annette will try to help her
like
put on makeup and she doesn't like
makeup and i feel like there's a lot of
support
conversations that are just someone
trying to put makeup on someone else see
there are a lot of things
yeah i mean they're teenagers
it's true golden deer are kind of i'm
ambivalent towards a lot of stuff i mean
they're just an alliance with nobles and
they don't have a great stake in
anything except for themselves
and that's why they're so fun to play as
yeah so like i would recommend a golden
deer play through for anyone and they
also have
two of my favorite characters i think
both my best boy and best girl
are golden deer students quad is cloud
your best boy no my best boy is raphael
raphael is i did not think i'd like him
yeah and then as i've been playing i'm
like all right
he's got a tragic backstory but he's
just so upbeat about everything and he's
just
full of positivity and he loves to eat
and every support conversation is like
let's eat you don't enough on your plate
let's have a good time let's go
let's party let's party yeah that's
that's golden deer in a nutshell
and leone who uh is like
uh geralt's uh apprentice and
she just she's just all about like being
better than you
she wants to like be as good as you and
like try and beat you but only
to protect you you know because you're
your old son and you know you're
basically like brother and sister
best boy best girl felix is my best boy
and right now my best girl
is probably bernadetta but i also really
like petra
and dorothea and
you want to recruit all the students if
you can because they're all so precious
those
girls there's except for lorenz yeah
yeah ash is a great
listen shamir or like shamir she can get
beyond students
she's my favorite teacher yeah i manuela
and hannah
in my current playthrough i'm trying to
get them to hook up yeah i don't think i
don't know if that's a thing
but in my mind like if i'm writing my
own little fan fiction in my head as
i'm playing like manuela and hannemann
have this like ongoing thing where they
bicker like an old married couple and
i'm like they're gonna
i'm gonna keep making them do group
tasks
[Applause]
are helping with the stables and that's
how you guys are going to fall in love
that's my whole plan
that's what i got going for me who's
your best boy and girl
i think probably ingrid oh yeah you love
ingrid
yeah ingrid and probably sylvain yeah
your best friend yeah i like sylvain i
feel like i've convinced myself
that black eagles is the best that
well i just all of my favorite girls are
from other houses
so that's my favorites are from other
houses too they're not from black eagles
so the
true best house is the friends we made
along
the way yeah no actually the best house
is on your second playthrough and you've
recruited everyone in your house
that's right it's like monster house
so basically we just like a lot of the
characters
and think girls are great so that's a
that's a good place to be
but uh we want to know what your
favorite and least favorite characters
are
in fire emblem three houses so let us
know in the comments and uh especially
if you hate lauren's you're our best
friend
as i've told you there is obviously a
conspiracy against me
there is no manner in which i could
possibly be considered bothersome
professor i assure you you have been
deceived
my adversary has poisoned the hearts of
these ladies against me